presence is the state of being attuned
to and able to comfortably express your
true self so your best qualities your
core values your personality and really
to do so under stressful circumstances
because when you can do that you're then
able to kind of let your guard down and
hear what's actually happening in the
situation rather than what you fear
might be happening presence comes from
knowing your story you know really
knowing who you are
so knowing what your core values are
what makes you you you know what's one
of the things about you that can't be
changed no matter how you perform in
this negotiation or on this math test so
it comes from knowing who you are
accepting who you are you know believing
your story and you know then being able
to access those things and sometimes
people have all of that but they can't
access it so when they when they get
into that stressful situation they go
into fight or flight mode and they
basically shut down and a wall comes up
and now they can't access the very tools
that they actually possess to do well in
that situation so they can't be present
it's just not possible everyone has
these biggest challenges and they are
situations that we approach with a sense
of dread that we execute with anxiety
and distraction we're thinking about
what they might be thinking of us what
we should have said two minutes ago
what's going to happen in the future and
then we leave them with a sense of
regret feeling that we weren't seeing
now what you know these big challenges
vary dramatically across people so for
some people it might be a job interview
for a lot of people it's a job interview
for some people it might be relationship
conflict at home for other people it
might be going to see the doctor and you
know making sure that you're getting all
the information you need so it varies
dramatically but I think that there are
sort of two key elements one is that it
feels very high-stakes so it feels like
whatever happens in that situation is
going to dramatically affect your life
and the other is that there's some
element of social judgement so somebody
is judging you
on a dimension that really matters to
you so you know are you a good person
are you a smart person are you a healthy
person you know so there's it's the
stakes are high and there's social
judgement now what happens when you put
these things together is that people
feel as if they are in a really
threatening situation and so their
nervous system sort of goes into this
fight-or-flight mode which might be
adaptive if you're being chased by a
tiger but you're not being chased by a
tiger in a job interview you're just in
a job interview and you're either going
to get the job or you're not going to
get the job that's it it's not adaptive
in the situations in which you see it
happen in today's world so I kind of
think that it's a it's it's sort of
evolution not catching up with with what
the real challenges are that we're
dealing with today the most important
thing I think is to know what are your
biggest challenges now you probably can
come up with some off the top of your
head but there might be some that you're
not even really aware of until you're in
them so I think one way to get at that
is to really pay attention to your body
what are the what's happening in the
moments when you tend to slouch and wrap
yourself up what's happening when you
start to breathe shallowly and quickly
what's happening when you start to sweat
you know what are the things that are
happening in the situation at those
moments when you're showing physical
signs of stress and anxiety and
depression and powerlessness
so once you've sort of identified what's
happening in the situation when those
things happen you start to become much
more attuned to those bodily cues and so
when they happen in the future you can
correct you can sort of course correct
earlier when people are present in a
social interaction you can tell now you
may not be conscious of what it is
you're noticing but you're picking up on
some things the first is that they
clearly believe their story so they buy
with their selling they truly buy what
they're selling you wouldn't buy
anything from somebody who wouldn't buy
what they're selling right you would
never do that although we've all
probably been instant
where we've had to try to sell something
that we don't really believe in so when
people are present they are attuned to
their true beliefs and values and
abilities and so they can really believe
their story and people see that
investors see that that's one of the
cues that investors really look for when
they're looking at pitches you know if
you say what are you looking for what
cues are you looking for when you're
judging pitches they don't say someone
who's totally calm they say someone who
believes their story and that takes it
sort of to the next one if you think
about investors they're not looking for
someone who's a hundred percent
confident in the kind of alpha way they
want somebody who's confident but not
arrogant so when you're truly confident
you don't need to be arrogant arrogance
is really just a smokescreen for
insecurity you know it's something that
people put up when they don't want to be
challenged it works in that moment but
it's not a sustainable strategy and if
you if you communicate arrogance and you
leave that situation the people who you
talk to you probably aren't going to
like you a whole lot right maybe you
weren't challenged in that moment but
you also didn't get the desired outcome
so confidence true confidence allows you
to be open to what other people are
saying so if you're bringing in an idea
that you really care about you should
want that idea to be as you know as good
as possible so you should want to be
open to constructive feedback right
people want to work with you if they see
you as a collaborator not someone who's
trying to say I have all the answers the
third thing that you see when somebody's
present is what I call synchrony across
the verbal and nonverbal channels and
what I mean by that is that when we are
being authentic and present and you
could think of it as when we're telling
the truth our words match our body
language so we're not having to manage
all of these things in a piecemeal kind
of robotic way it's not choreographed if
we're telling a happy story our body's
doing the things that we do when we feel
happy that's how you see authenticity we
know that from the research on lie
detection which everyone sort of
interested in lie detection
and if you ask people how do you know if
somebody's lying they will say eye
contact it turns out that I contact is
not a good way to know if somebody's
lying there are big personality
differences some people don't want to
make eye contact when they're being you
know challenged or questioned but that
doesn't mean they're lying there are
cultural differences in some cultures
children are taught you don't ever look
up at or make eye contact with somebody
who's questioning you right so it's just
not a good cue and in fact there's no
single body language cue that gives away
lying
there's no Pinocchio effect the nose
doesn't grow you know there's nothing
like that you can tell if somebody's
being inauthentic or if somebody's lying
by watching you know whether or not
their words and body language are
synchronized when you are lying or being
inauthentic because you're scared to
show people who you are you're trying to
put you know you you're trying to
communicate something that's not exactly
real right so the story that you're
telling is not going to match what
you're doing with your body language
because you don't have the cognitive
bandwidth to manage all of those
different elements because think about
it you've got words you've got tone of
voice how quickly are you talking I mean
that's just we're still just at speaking
um then you have your eyes and the rest
of your face what are you doing with
your lower body you know your arms your
feet all of those things come together
when you're telling the truth when
you're being inauthentic it leaks out
somewhere there is an asynchronous and
when you are not being present it leaks
out in the same way I don't think that
one achieves presence so I don't think
that you get to a point where you are
permanently present in a sort of
monk-like state of presence and and I
say that because I actually think that
sort of in the the second half of the
20th century a lot of the a lot of the
writings about presence kind of implied
that that's what you're going for that
you're going well but either at stage
presence and charisma which is a totally
different thing or it's this permanent
state of presence that you achieve if
you
work for your whole life and maybe the
day before you die suddenly you become
present and that's daunting you know no
one can be present all the time because
we're human and we're distracted there's
too much going on so of course we're
going to be distracted